well police in Cincinnati are
investigated what prompted an off-duty
officer to fire his stun gun at an
11-year old girl
authorities say the officer suspected
the girl was shoplifting Monday at a
Kroger supermarket where he worked
another job the officer approached her
but they say she tried to flee that's
when he used his son gun to shock her in
the back the girl's mother is demanding
answers nobody else's kids so there
could have been worse it could have been
a gun the 11-year old was charged with
theft and obstruction of justice but
those charges have now been dropped the
officer is on restricted duty pending an
investigation the police union has not
responded to our request for comment
in a statement Cincinnati Police told
CBS News quote we are extremely
concerned when force is used by one of
our officers on a child of this age as a
result we will be taking a very thorough
review of our policies current
Cincinnati Police policy allows tasers
to be used on people who are as young as
seven Kroger tells CBS News it's
assisting local law enforcement with
their investigations one of those ones
you're scratching your head yeah I
didn't you can tase little kids at the
age of seven no there's always two sides
to every story but seems like a better
way to handle that one yeah